I cried because I really felt very
frightened I didn't know how to cope
with a Nobel Peace Prize
I was very ordinary young woman living
in a community and though I worked in
the community I was never very party
political in that sense and I felt
extremely overwhelmed by what was going
to happen and all of a sudden the word
press landed in the piece heist and I
was being asked big questions like how
do you get world peace and what would I
know about getting her peace
so I did find it very overwhelming well
I was afraid but and for the first few
years that I carried the Nobel Prize and
going to different countries and as I
carried that fear and sense of
insecurity but gradually I overcame that
fear and I begun to accept and enjoy and
love the great privilege of being able
to carry the Nobel Prize and use it for
others and go into situations were like
Adolfo Perez under house arrest in
Argentina going to Argentina made Adolfo
and be able to use the prize to help
people who needed to help at that time
so now I just love being the Nobel Prize
my grateful for it and I try to use it
as best as possible
to help others